please welcome james beard award-winning
kwame on watchy
i'm so happy to be back i mean i'm so
happy that you're back on the show and
i'm not gonna hesitate to brag you are
number one on amazon for your cookbook
right now and it hasn't even come out
thanks
we did it we're doing it i mean how good
does that feel it feels so good for a
multitude of reasons right like i'm able
to really share my culture and i think
so many people have different versions
of what american food was for them
growing up yeah for me it was curry
chicken oxtails you know jell-off rice a
goosey soup so this book is uh my love
letter back to america it's full of all
the recipes that i've cooked and all the
classics so we're gonna cook one today i
cannot wait teach me everything
loving the new season of top chapter
it's good it's so good it's been fun
it's been a lot of fun oh good and it's
in houston which is a great city i know
i'm loving this season so much all right
so what we're going to do first is we're
going to make our green seasoning so
green seasoning is a caribbean marinade
it goes with vegetables it goes with
meats
and we're just going to add this to the
blender so we have green onions all of
our aromatics in there we have some
celery thyme
we have ginger garlic paste ginger
garlic paste and then we have some you
like your food spicier i do i do
it's because i've dulled this palette
over the years two years so then we have
some pepper sauce
so just put that on top
and hit that button
and i want the crowd to go go go go go
go
go go go go go go
that's it
that's it bad enough yes enough i hate
when it like frappes too much and it
starts to get foamy yeah
so put some a little bit of oil in there
the whole thing or just a just a little
bit there you go you're going to add
your onions to that
oh yeah sounds good right it does i love
a sizzle we're going to add our
green seasoning
and you can smell this already yeah you
want to get all that oh yeah you do this
is why i love a silicone spoon
exactly
then we have two spice blends so the
toasted curry powder
and then we have a house spice which is
my mom's all-purpose seasoning it's
something that she always kept in arm's
reach when she was making any dish
so there's like coriander there's
fenugreek there's tumeric there's cumin
i love fenugreek and then in the house
spice is like uh you know black pepper
cayenne
um
garlic powder onion powder so there's so
much cumin i love it i smell the cumin
so much flavor developing i don't know
about anybody else but cumin to me
smells like a sexy boyfriend t-shirt
so you got that you're going to add your
chickpeas to that okay
and this is a quick dish you know but it
has a lot of flavor that's built up and
that's what a lot of the recipes are
indicative of that are in this book this
is a mixed battle is just insane it is
so
vibrant
so
so on my side i kind of got the same
thing going on here i've had chicken
that's been marinating for 24 hours in
that green seasoning i've seared it
uh put some of the seasoning to the side
okay and i'm gonna add it back to the
pan
so i'm gonna mirror what you're doing
the scent of this it's like curry
another lemon tree growing out of it and
onion and garlic and
the pepper
so you got that simmering i've got mine
simmering
and then you just put a lid on it next
to you we have something on it that's it
and next to you you got the curry
already ready to go look at how
absolutely
stunning
this is could i put it off yeah put it
right on there
i'm going to put chicken on mine
it just falls off the bone kwame could
you
just put some chopped uh cilantro on
there i am so excited cheers
oh
i'm so happy to be back with you
and i'm
oh man
right
getting that heat up in the nose
um
really
really hearty
very comforting the chickpeas are melt
in your mouth yeah it's so beautiful
thank you thank you mommy no wonder
you're number one with a bullet on
amazon before your book even came out
thank
[Applause]
i mean and i just have to say as a
cookbook club person and a collector of
cookbooks i love the cover of your book
i think it's really soulful and
beautiful it feels personal it's graphic
i love the font you chose and it just
makes me want to dive in thank you thank
you you know it's really a collection of
stories big enough the people that came
before me you know the people that
really made these recipes who they are
there's anecdotes before each recipe
that tells you the history of jerk that
tells you the path that curry took to
the caribbean so you get to really know
the why behind why these dishes have
stood the test of time for so long well
you're such an honoring person it really
doesn't surprise me so get your copy now
of my america recipes from a young black
chef available on may 17th already
number one
[Music]